but yeah i hate to date the video but uh
i just want to talk about this one thing
uh that i saw on twitter this morning
right uh
[Music]
old news by the time so probably all
news by the time this comes out but i
just couldn't [ __ ] believe it um
snoop dogg
has joined faze clan
what i'm not even joking
he has joined face clan as
faze snoop
okay okay what do you think about
okay okay i might be out of touch here
yeah what is a face client well like i
know
faze clan but
i don't know facetime what are face clan
like like what is a phase called what
it's um you know it's a it was
originally a youtuber organization and
now it's an esports organization right
yeah and then it's so so they always had
it was back in the day when cod started
it yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's how it started i
followed it then but like they've seemed
to like
just gone out of that little bubble i
don't know what phase is anymore i don't
know either are they just like a like a
youtube house
no it's like a brand and you know if you
if you're
anointed interface
pointed
united interface you get uh
you do genuinely get a lot of success
just yeah yeah yeah it's a very powerful
brand yeah with younger audiences
normally yeah yeah
not
a lot of people
our age watch facebook are they still 15
16 yeah are they still an esports
organization or yeah they do everything
it's kind of like a brand you know
there's okay that's kind of what that
that's it's like an agency yeah so it's
from what i understand it's more of an
agency right but but all of the esports
brands
are all kind of going that way right now
because they realize that relying only
on esports is not the best for business
yeah because you can you know if your
team competes only
four times six times a year that's you
you have to you can only monetize the
sponsors and then those events yeah
whereas if you're you're an entertainer
you can monetize every time they upload
or do something yeah
i mean now it just seems like a lot of
esports organizations are just streamer
organizations because that's that's what
i feel with like with face phase clan
now i'm just like are they still the
esports organization or the uh
entertainment i always thought it was
like i always thought it was like you
know kind of like uh factioned off
whereas like these like we have a bunch
of face clan members who are like the
esports players who don't go on twitch
or youtube or anything yeah and then we
have the youtubers and then we have the
twitch streamers and then you know well
a lot of the time as well they they want
to get
the the best players in
uh a game or a genre because
normally the best players at any game if
they stream they will have an audience
yeah uh
not necessarily always but they have a
lot better chance of getting an audience
right right you know yeah and you can
kind of help them and coach them through
it well they're definitely going to get
a bigger audience now now that the snoop
doo double g has joined i don't know for
some reason when i heard that i'm just
like that doesn't sound surprising to me
i don't know why i don't know why i'm
just like
does some interesting business i'm sure
the deal is very good for snoop oh yeah
i'm sure it's an extremely good deal i'm
sure he needs the money
but to me has the same energy of uh do
you remember like back when you know uh
when e3 happened and you'd see like
these press conferences and then like at
every like e3 presentation they'd be
they'd have this like run one random
celebrity come on to promote their games
like i don't know like [ __ ] drake
promoting madden or something you know
what i mean yeah that it has the same
energy as that for me
it does yeah where you just get like
this random
this random celebrity to promote your
brand or to your game
um and it wouldn't make any sense but
you know i just it makes
it makes sense because it's so it's such
meme worthy that people are going to
talk about it anymore oh yeah of course
and sleep dog has done plenty of [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah yeah i mean he's so amazingly
in touch with like internet audiences
and just meme culture that like he's
it's just like a win for him it's just i
don't know there's something weird about
this is something weird about when he's
always we have to call him face snoop
now he's always posting on instagram and
stuff and all that
and he like like doxed his uber driver
or something what he like doxxed his
like delivery or door dash person yeah
because they didn't like deliver the
food right he like showed a picture in
their first name
to all of his followers oh my god
because he was shown the interaction
right i was angry that he i think super
dog was upset that they didn't deliver
the food and i think snoop was trying to
tell him where to go all right because
obviously snoop lives in like a
gated community all right it's probably
a bit harder to give it to him yeah yeah
and he was like complaining on his
twitter and showed the face and name of
the person and this guy got like a lot
of hate i think jesus poor guy poor guy
i don't know just
for me it's like really fascinating just
watching these like very
traditional celebrities and like music
artists and whatnot like kind of really
dig their heels into things like twitch
and youtube and stuff like that you know
like when i found out like you know
t-pain
regularly streams on twitch and he has
like a pretty [ __ ] massive order he
plays streams on twitch yeah t-pain
t-pain is massive on twitch dude like he
he's been streaming
constantly right like like everyone
wonders oh what happened to t-pain he's
on twitch now
he's just streaming like dead mouse as
well he's just streaming on twitter yeah
i know deadmau5 streaming twitch and
it's just i don't know it's it's really
bizarre that like uh at least i find it
very bizarre to see these like people
who usually ever see yeah the people
you'd only ever see on like tv shows and
like music videos and stuff like that
just suddenly being like
oh yeah you know i just dropped a five
dollar donation to t-pain the other day
on twitch you know
this is weird to say out loud i don't
know d-pain stream
he's streaming for 100 hours he's got
the analytics
he's active normally one day a week one
day okay and normally uh
he seems quite wild i think i'm sure i'm
sure he's busy doing other things sure
he's streaming
right yeah
he's changed more than god yes he's more
than me i'll tell you that
oh wow yeah he's quite active yeah
i was surprised i just ran because i
remember i was just like going through
twitch one day and you know like the
channels you should watch thing came up
and on the top of it it just said t-pain
i was like that can't be the same t-pain
right the guy who wrote
through the fire in flames
oh the guitarist for the dragon force
yeah he streams the guitarist and the
drummer actually
really regularly i remember they wanted
to perform their song but they couldn't
for copyright reasons yeah yeah that's
that sounds like it sounds like the age
of the internet yeah right copyright
laws are broken yeah no like i remember
like when uh
well they were there
when like gordon ramsay replied to xqc
or something
about the cooking thing that that was so
surreal
i i don't think that's called i'm pretty
sure that's just someone managing his
account but i think gordon has very good
people in charge i don't know because
gordon's pretty active on like tick tock
right he's pretty active on like social
media platforms
that he's he's he's keeping up with it
yeah i think gordon has a very good team
of
zoomers
like teaching him and telling him what
to do because like in his life in one of
his videos he just kept talking about
uncle roger and i was like you obviously
have someone who's like keeping you in
touch and telling you
well obviously yeah we've talked about
how whoever they've hired for like the
kitchen nightmares um titles on youtube
right yeah like top 10 times the food
was busting kids yeah
like that was like an actual youtube
title like what is happening
and it worked it worked it got so many
[ __ ] views yeah it's like a [ __ ]
decade old show now or something
his accounts are like on top of their
[ __ ] oh yeah i i i don't even want to
know how much the kitchen nightmares
youtube account makes because i've
noticed as well the youtube kitchen
nightmares account
literally just repost the same clips
with different titles and different
montages all the time really they'll be
like
chopped 10 times the burger was good and
then i'll next one be like top 10 times
the food was good and they'll just reuse
the same clips yeah yeah so they just
keep making different lists and then
reusing the same clips because it's
finite there's only they don't have
right more than what they have now yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's generally how
they've been daily uploading and keep
uploading stuff it's genius though
because whenever i don't know about you
guys but whenever a kitchen nightmares i
watch it clip shows off my timeline
there i always got time i would even if
i've seen this clip like 10 million
times before all right how awesome is it
actually i gotta find out
pitching nightmares
and i think another one was like when
the food wasn't busted top 10 times the
food wasn't busting okay right kitchen
nightmares gets
on average or
fluctuates from anywhere between
30 to 70 million views a month holy [ __ ]
right
that's probably in the range of like uh
it could be anywhere from like a hundred
to two hundred grand a month well yeah
knowing how well food channels do yeah
it's probably two hundred thousand two
hundred
dollars yeah which is what which makes
me wonder why don't more reality tv
shows post as many [ __ ] clips as they
possibly can probably because a lot of
their production team are out of touch
or maybe some copyright issues
probably a mixture of things also
probably a lack of faith that they'll do
well yeah yeah you know nightmares brand
is still very strong
yeah
like what what show were you thinking of
specifically like pretty much any
reality tv show i feel like big brother
like 90 day fiance yeah you know like
any any basically anything made by tlc
like [ __ ] the bachelors like [ __ ]
like that like i feel like reality tv in
like
especially reality tv was meant to be
watched in a group well tlc uploads
clips
all the time that's why they're so they
do so well because they upload all the
clipable moments that's that's how 90
day fiance got big to begin with right
it's because the clips went viral
i i would like i i wonder if it would do
even better on like if they
not only uploaded whole episodes but
like uploaded a whole episode uploaded
clips uploaded like [ __ ] montages
like with the kitchen nightmare things
because it feels like
this kind of content is just infinitely
recyclable because it's content that
you're gonna [ __ ] watch whenever you
have like a lunch and you need to sit
down and you're like what clip do i want
to watch oh maybe i'll just watch
kitchen nightmares maybe i'll just watch
nine state fiance again the same [ __ ]
big head clip or whatever you know
you can never get tired of them you're
just you'll just never get tired of that
right the clip of somebody who's over
like 600 pounds yeah
or someone with like a gross uh you know
obsession or yeah
coffee animal i like smelling buttholes
thank you
was it like what was that show like my
weird my session
the one about the coffee enema gets me
every time i'm just like there's no way
someone actually does that and they do
and like gross the one thing that makes
me cringe the most for some reason is
the it was this one british woman who uh
eats concrete
oh yeah yeah yeah and it wasn't the fact
that she was just better than british
food
that is a british delicacy right
developing a strong jawline with that
one yeah you told me they were like why
do legos have do not eat warnings and
british food doesn't
[Music]
validate that's true no it was just like
the noise that it made when she was
crunching oh she was crunchy
yeah
you know that feeling where you
accidentally get sand in your mouth and
it's just like
i don't know it's just the worst problem
[Music]
feeling alone that feeling i i
understand anakin for that one for that
one moment where you accidentally get
sand in your mouth and you just spend
the next five minutes just like oh
there's just a weird crunch in there
yeah yeah i can't get rid of it i think
maybe the reason why like a lot of like
you know shows like that reality tv
shows don't post clips and full episodes
i think it's because a lot of their like
this is just speculation but i'm
guessing a lot of like the producers and
the production team and the people
behind the actual show still have some
level of faith that people still watch
tv like they're used to back in the day
and so they're like well i mean we're
still getting numbers maybe not as big
as you know back in the autumn but you
know people still watching tv i also
imagine that maybe if you're producing a
lot of shows i imagine there has been a
lot of shows that just lost because they
didn't archive them properly or they
didn't yeah they don't have the files or
they they have them they just don't know
what which one's which yeah i imagine
there's a lot of that going on probably
copyright you know like maybe the
production team made it and then sold it
to a network and maybe the network
doesn't have the rights and the
production team doesn't uh maybe they
also don't have the rights and i'm sure
they didn't build those contracts you
know with the clause of like oh you know
if these go on youtube then we hold all
the rights i'm sure they
yeah but like a show from the 2000s
probably not
yeah like i noticed right now especially
like whenever i go on my netflix holy
[ __ ] they make a lot of reality tv shows
like with like every single genre right
it doesn't matter yeah i remember when
netflix is like picking an occupation
this is probably a reality show
you watch that one no no there's a glass
one there's a glass blowing like of
course there is like competition i
watched like the full series i don't
know why did i have like the reality tv
like interviews it was like master chef
with glasses oh my god and they had like
the archetypes of the glass-blowing
judges they were like the you know
like the gordon ramsay the the the nice
one the mean one i can't believe he just
said that about my face
[Music]
is it like exactly the same format and
everything like that yeah but like you
have now 30 minutes to make your your
glass it is literally like a master chef
that replaced with glass blood oh my god
it wasn't that
i remember when like netflix was like
just [ __ ] out like five
documentaries a day and now they've
they're like shutting out five different
reality tv shows today
i've got a season two and no game no
life didn't